H and we're live don't care hello good
morning good afternoon good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and welcome to CIT your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel and we're joined by sci-fi
Quest look hello sci-fi Quest guys how
you doing um I always love saying that
little bit good morning good afternoon
good evening wherever the hell you in
the world just because we actually get
viewed from people all over the world
it's still me you know just blows my
mind well I do say the first 30 second
you know of views well yeah so just just
give everybody a little I love you guys
all over the world anyway um we thought
we'd get you on Melvin and just talk a
little bit about what's going on oh we
have a new member by the way kaha thank
you very much sir I wanted to tip my hat
to you so thank
youa um that's that throws me back to my
days when I used to do
karate Kate as well everybody did it one
point in because we had the Karate Kid
and then everybody went I can do
that waack on waxs off all this I can do
that you can try oh yeah know I just got
punched in the face a lot but you know
it was all good Andrew how are you sir
Davey B is with us how are you guys how
you doing man Laura Smith Melvin in the
house um we're going to talk a little
bit about starget because I wanted to
your opinion on a couple of things and I
wanted to announce what we're doing
tomorrow because we're do something very
very cool
tomorrow um we're going to talk monster
movies because there's a we've had a few
little updates on a few um aliens we got
monik coming out soon we got well the
trailer dropped well we saw a couple of
trailers for godia minus one which we
wanted to talk about and the trailer for
Echo dropped and we're going to talk a
little bit about Marvel which might turn
into US complaining about Marvel but
we'll see how it goes sure Sarah you're
in with us as well it's it's the usual
Bunch we absolutely love it so first of
all I wanted to well I'll tell you what
we're doing tomorrow on um SRE live on
Sunday we're starting a bit of a new
format we're going to have what I think
will turn into an argument but the idea
is to do a presidential debate style
thing so I am going to be arguing that
we should get a TV series Harris is
going to be arguing
well yeah Harris is going to be arguing
we should get the movie they planned and
we're basically going to try to help
Amazon and MGM to make the right
decision because they seem to be
uncertain which way to go so lots of
infighting
and because of the strikes theyve it's
given them time to think and that's
never a good idea and the man united are
playing at the
moment 20 minutes remaining midfields a
Shambo
s so um so if you see me just like going
it's because it's nil nil um so first of
all how are you doing Melvin are you had
a good week mate and what you doing on
your Channel at the moment and um tell
the people why they should go and join
you there's a link by the way in the
description for for Melvin's Channel
cool right yeah so uh yeah I've been
good um I've started up on making my
babyon 5 reaction videos again it's been
a couple of weeks of a gap in between
but uh they're doing very
well got a love babon
five yeah it's it's I honestly think it
was groundbreaking and so many shows
like have been copying it ever since
scii show controversy when batt 5 came
out was DS9 was a copy yeah which it was
technically because they
even I can never pronounce his name he
actually took um the producer Star Trek
to court and won J melinski yeah that's
the one it's I can't pronounce his name
JMS just say
JM
J because he actually won and then um
put it all all the money he won from the
court case he actually just put straight
into the show and it and you can and you
can see it when you watch it it's
amazing yeah yeah yeah um but then I
think I mean I I see would argue that
Babylon 5 by um um more um kind of
copied it as well but not the storyline
the style because there was a distinct
style to the way the battle scenes and
things and everyone looked over at the B
sorry that
Umar Galactica was this amazing new St
I'm like I'm looking at Babylon 5 going
okay yeah they did it
cheaper but the fundamentals were there
you know know the sound and the way the
ships moved and things like this and I'm
like I think um Ronald De Moore might
have been a Babylon 5 fan but anyway
possibly yeah I with the batt 5 it was
it was all CGI there was no actual
physical models in the studi so it's not
like not the same with DS9 DS9 they had
it was both I think they were using
models and CGI they would just
moving Deep Space 9 would have been
using still using solid models at that
point yeah yeah then vo St Trek with
full CGI by by six or sorry sry seven
season three or four of df9 they started
using more CGI but I mean even in the
big um Dominion Wars that's one of the
reasons why you see so many excelsis
still fighting and getting blown up
because they had the models to destroy
so um
but they were all CGI so many
mirandas yeah every time you go to you
see [__] battle you see like three or
four mirandas in
formation
Yeahs but I mean the flashback episode
of DS9 when they had the Enterprise that
was a big thing at the time because the
that was the first time we've seen the
original Enterprise by
CGI one of the best to episodes they
went back to as well because they went
back to trial trials and tribulations I
think it was wasn't
it yeah um and you see that brilliant
episode thing where um James T Kirk is
bollocking them and um because they've
started a fight with the King guns and
it's a mix of the original crew and like
O'Brien stood there and stuff really
good but it did they did get was there
as well yeah bash was there they did it
absolutely beautifully the
famous we don't like to talk about it
yeah yeah yeah we just don't talk about
we don't talk about the we don't like
talk
about but to talk about Stargate very
briefly because I just wanted your
opinion we're doing this presidential
debate style tomorrow stormy is going to
be
mediating um so um which he's
disappointed by because it means he
can't get involved in the actual
argument um H oh God hunda
to hunda I can't even I I'm struggling
with that but hello from
Germany K Blends in Germany I've been
there um
so
Stargate I we dropped the news and it
was actually confirmed by Jenny styen
MGM um Insider on the live last week
that there was a meeting a couple of
weeks ago where basically the top bosses
of um amaz
said to because there's been a lot of
infighting for ages a lot of Executives
and a lot of people mainly MGM have been
saying we want to do a series please God
don't do a movie um you know a series
would work better but Amazon have always
said no we're going to do this straight
to cinema movie two weeks or three near
three weeks ago now the top bosses of
Amazon basically said right to the
people that were arguing movie and I
thinking Michael Wright who's the head
of MGM plus was really the main focal
point of this basic so they basically
said to him right do a presentation tell
us why we should do a series what why
would we and again I imagine lots of
Powerpoints and them go no this this is
a pie chart on why people want a TV
series not a movie and that sort of
thing but it's opened up a can of worms
because of the strikes and everything
everything's on pause anyway they've
been reviewing everything that they were
doing and it's just opened up this
possibility now I'm not saying this
point that they've gone with a series or
a movie it seems to be still up in the
air a little
bit but there is a possibility that they
might take what they've done prepare
them for the movie and just shift it
into a series there's no I'm not being
told they're going to scrap it I'm
basically told them they'll just divert
it and re redo what they've done not
waste anything hopefully and just
blah I just wondered before we get into
the debate tomorrow what do you think if
do you have any did you have any
thoughts what's on
that well selfishly as a Stargate fan I
want a series I want the show but I can
also see the benefits of them doing the
movie because uh then they because then
they'll Revitalize the cinema right
people start go I'd go to cinema to see
a stargame regardless so I mean no twice
and the cinemas they need to have movies
pumped into them right now because no
one's going so they need to have uh some
have a franchise like Stargate on the
big screen I have a feeling that people
are going to go and see it I mean you're
going to get new fans from a new movie
right so that will benefit the show and
it will benefit Amazon because they'll
have an influx of extra cash instead of
like these other stream Services where
they're pleading money left right center
and um I've always thought
that if Amazon does decide to go with
the series I'd be perfectly happy 100%
if they just decide I'm gonna that
they're gonna make a movie and then put
it in the sumar just just like a
spin-off maybe um maybe follow some
other SG teams right yeah there a it's a
huge Universe in Stargate and we just
all we've seen is we' saw Stargate we've
seen Atlantis we've seen Universe right
so it'll be nice to see a new group of
people going off in a different
direction and then maybe that team
cameos in the series and then they have
like a spin-off movie series that sort
of
yeah that would be a huge benefit to the
franchise what do you think so one of
the arguments was franchises aren't
doing well at the cinema at the moment
Marvel
DC um all of these other things the
Marvel stuff now well well we'll go to
Marvel later but Indiana Jones it's not
been doing well you
know Disney mostly Yeah Yeah well yeah
but the last Miss Impossible film bombed
oh
yeah so but but these films I mean
Indiana Jones and um them they both did
well when they were then released
electronically
so well yeah but it wasn't because they
were bad
films well they rewrote the Indiana
Jones and they literally just reshot
half of it so well yes they did oh God
the cost of that film was
just but um my point is though that is
this going to be so so so one of the
arguments was well Stargate won't do
well because it's a franchise I would
argue Top Gun did very well last year
because it was bringing back a franchise
and there was a bit of retro you know
and it was a bit of you know people
harking back to things so if you think
of it not as a franchise like Marvel but
a franchise like Top Gun maybe it could
do very very well at the
cinema well I'd say more more likely
look at
Godzilla
which about that in a
minute about minute but I mean it's just
a perfect example of um franchises that
have the potential and can do really
well I mean how long have been going on
for since
53 huge
franchise I mean you could also like the
um um Planet of the Apes movies I think
we got another one of those coming out
shortly I had a video on that
Thursday I think or was it Friday yeah
so I've done a video on that and looks
absolutely stunning oh I will not
watching it I have not I watched the
first one absolutely hated it I don't
like the Planet of the Apes movies
anyway and
and yeah and it's not for me not for me
I won't be watching the new one um bcks
to it so um and in in my own thing but
they've been quietly making money doing
very well for their home Studios not
make not losing any money just cracking
on moving forwards and Eric makes two
more Marshal and mounts have come on for
God sake
um where is it
United I love you I'm so last time I
wore a man united short shirt I was with
a friend who was in a wheelchair and we
went to watch a Watford game and man you
were playing then I had a man shirt
underneath a Watford
shirt to my heart Watford
shirt my local local teams that makes
sense I supported both but you know what
man you should win uh I went to watch a
Wolves game because my mate had um a box
and I was literally the only one wearing
a man united shirt I didn't give a crap
and we [__] him as well few years ago
I went to Old Trafford and watched one
of their um their Replay Games I for
what they call it um it was is it a b
munic game they re redid it they had all
the same players on the pitch it was
amazing yeah oh bu and get yes I do know
what you mean but anyway um with the
Stargate because because people don't
want to talk about man united let's be
honest um I don't even want to talk
about man united I want to pretend it's
not happening but um get all
that so with the Stargate then I
actually think there's a there there is
a possibility it could do very well and
at the end of the day um is it a bit
old-fashioned though to think that a
franchise will do better if you get a
big cinematic movie I mean imagine right
if the Cinematic movie bombs that kills
the franchise immediately but if it does
really really you know does really
well it Kickstart a franchise to the
next 20 years yeah cany yeah 100% but um
the thing is that a lot of people are a
bit tired of franchises right
now like I said we're going to get into
Marvels like a little bit later but I
mean there perfect examples you
know yeah even me one of the franchises
you can think that people aren't
interested in that much is probably Star
Trek you have to be a Star Trek fan
either for the new ones or the old ones
and there and there's a lot of an
arguments between the two right um some
saying oh it's not canon then others are
saying oh yeah but it doesn't have to be
Canon it's a it's a
huge loads of people just hate it when
you say bad bad stuff about it but it is
actually true I mean
some
good I'm trying to find out a little bit
about Star Trek at the moment because
there's some I've been told a couple of
rumors this morning that um they're
interesting but I'll I'll talk about
that later in the week because I got got
to find out a bit more for myself I got
to dig into it a little bit but my
argument with Star
Trek is that the first couple of seasons
of Discovery actually discovery full is
crap I don't like it it's
boring love the first season strange new
worlds I was disappointed by the second
but the animated stuff is great and um I
can see that there there's a future for
Star Trek but
[Music]
um we need less of it there was too much
there was five shows at one point that's
too much
um and then um because people do get
fatigued but Paramount have tried to do
something different with it and I hope
they don't try to do this with Stargate
to be honest because Paramount what
they've done is they've tried to do five
different shows for five different
demographics basically a younger show a
kids show and they were thinking and
they were quite proud of it saying that
you know like if we do this if you don't
like that Star Trek just watch another
Star Trek just watch the other one
instead and and then that was their
philosophy and I'm like that's the
stupidest philosophy on the planet do a
Star Trek show I like sci-fi I will
watch different types of Star Trek show
but aiming it solely at children solely
at um you know 18 to 24s and then we'd
gotard season 3 for us trekkies and I'm
like that's an idiotic way to do it just
make good shows I mean thing me
traditional Star Trek has always
Incorporated every single one of them I
mean it's always had something for
everyone you know just say it's the UK
it's the middle afternoon for us I even
consider bringing a beer up with
me hey Jess how you
doing um yeah um yeah so we'll see but I
don't think Amazon is stupid enough to
do that with star because I do think
it's a bit of a failed experiment with
with Star Trek and hopefully they learn
the lesson from it yeah um but they
don't seem to be so but let's let's
thing
um Andrew's made a good point here I
know quite a few people go to the cinema
regularly but won't subscribe to steam
and service so it's a chance to pick up
all new Stargate fans usually sub to
streaming
service it's good point I yeah but I
think there's a there's a really good
point for why Disney movies are doing
particularly badly not just because
they've got a bit of a bad reputation at
the moment and they have made some
absolute stinkers of movies don't get me
wrong they've made some really bad
films um but they've also made some good
films that have still bombed and I
think I think there's a argument to say
people can't be asked to go and watch
films at the cinema where it costs 20
pound a ticket when they know it's going
to be on Disney Plus in a couple of
months and say it's 20 quid of 20 qu a
ticket and then how much is a bottle how
much is a drink how much is
um oh I took my kids and spent a100
pound a couple month you easily spend
100 pound plus just to go and see a
movie that's an hour and a half to two
hours long yeah you're don't sit without
a drink are you yeah or you wait for a
couple of
months and it's on Disney plus that you
already pay for you know because I can't
actually get to a cinema right now so I
can't go and see them so I wait until I
come out on streaming because I got my
truck I would go with cinemar I mean but
like I say it's just difficult cost of
living and stuff well and and that's the
point is that this cost of living so I
mean how do you justify that when you
know you've maybe not got as much money
in the bank the moment as You' like have
a free kick in a dangerous area for
God's sake I think this is going to go
nil
nil United anyway so yeah I I think
they've really shot themselves in the
foot but while we're talking about those
let's talk about Marvel
because the Echo trailer dropped this
week it look amazing I pointed you
towards it because it's it genu looks
really good yeah I literally just
watched it earlier today after Jay
mentioned
it um yeah I think I think
they right so Andrew says I don't think
it's franchise is dead as much as it's
peeper a little over comic book movies
and I think that's true I think people
are going a bit but also argue the
movies have been bad which is why people
got bored of
them point he's right because um
Invincible season 2 has just started on
Amazon Prime right and I watched it and
I was like this is actually a really
good comic based superhero show might be
an animated series but it's it's on the
level of the boys if you know I mean
it's just yeah yeah well as blood it's
not it's not a young kids car animated
show you know it's and that that is it's
it's it can be a very popular show it
can be very very
popular I've gone off it they go it goes
too far for me it's too much boys um and
this new genv it put me off it put me
off
immediately um but um I I don't think
I'll be watching it but um I loved the
boys the first season I adored it I
enjoyed the second season but the third
season I was just like I started this
I'm started to go this is just too much
I don't I don't I don't need okay the
guy's got a dick that's like 12 feet
long
okay um and that joke went on a manga
movie well yeah it just went too far for
meated manga stuff that is Yeah
Yeahs yeah David damn it golford thing
only joking
David
um so
um I honestly think that Marvel have
done some absolutely stinking movies
that's that's why people have been
turning off Marvel because they've been
bad um Doctor Strange 2 was bad I me
that's some good bits in it but it was
generally not very good so wakanda
forever except for that second film
because it was not very boring went on
So and I've got Wings on my feet so off
you just like an idiot you're the least
scary that guy comes flying towards me
like oh he's going to kill me this um
idiot um it's that just made some bad
stuff I'm not looking forward to iron
heart that looks stupid oh
that and so yeah but they've done some
really really crap stuff David if you're
joking Bruno
Bruno one Dave Dave Dave thank you sir
Bruno scored and he's in my dream team
as well double
trouble just don't say this
loud sorry sorry sorry Bruno Bruno Bruno
um the last Guardians of the movie yeah
was melancholic again if it had been
like half an hour shorter and they like
trimmed it down a little bit and made it
a little bit more focused I think it
could have been really good but it's
just too it went on too much it's two
half yeah I mean the problem with that
the only reason I actually watched
Guardians was because of Nathan Fon yeah
at the last one that's the only reason I
watched it because I I love naan for
Leon Firefly and all that amazing stuff
rookie and and that it was just really
good even Castle a lot of the castle I
watched yeah I love Nathan fillian
he's if they get to make those Firefly
movies that he's pushing for at the
moment I would adore it um that yeah
Andrew that's not a rumor that is I mean
um a f came out and basically um said
about 12 months ago they've been pushing
to do too much too fast and he was
slamming the brakes on um and they were
going to redo a fair bit and they did
basically the same thing with Star Wars
about eight or nine months ago they
basically did the same thing we're doing
too much too fast and I think they
basically had a conversation with a CGI
company and the CGI people went if you
don't slow down we're quitting and now
they've um they've unionized so they
ain't going to have a Choice um but yeah
the that is the fact that Marvel have
slowed down Echo though if you haven't
seen the trailer for it go check it
out Kingpin is in it it looks like he's
gonna have a big part in it and he is
amazing um not dead looks like he been
shot in the eye from the trailer he's
got a patch over his eye when he's
talking in the eye man fuses to die um
but it looked like Daredevil was in as
well I saw I saw a flash in that trailer
yeah there must have be some sort of tie
in Daredevil um wouldn't surprise me
even though they've decided that they
want to redo all of the
essentially yes they they've scrapped
what they' started yeah apparently right
now this is rumor but apparently they
were going um they tied it in a little
bit with
She-Hulk and when they then realized
that She-Hulk was was not well
received um they've basically decided
scrap it basically they've done with
Daredevil what what Amazon are doing
with Stargate at the moment and they're
just going is this the right way and
they but with Marvel have gone no and so
they've just completely scrapped it and
they're rewriting everything and or they
had been filming four three or four
months and they're scrapping it all of
it it's going on the
exactly I think was it they filmed what
was it 13 episodes was it I think it was
supposed to be uh I don't I don't think
they filmed out eight weeks so they
wouldn't have filmed more than one maybe
two episodes or plan they wouldn't film
in order anyway though would they they'd
be filming a bit of episode one a bit
episode nine and a bit they they do it
by sort of like where they setups they
set up somewhere film there b ble side
Galactica where you know they have to
film it in the week because that's how
long they had because it was on the foll
week right yeah exactly do old days to
entertainment yeah oh sometimes they'll
film the end at the start and all sorts
it depends
on cost effective the way there was most
efficient it works it works well in most
cases but sometimes you can see the
continuity
issue yeah issues regardless but it's
impossible to record things in an order
um I do think it's better when they
record an episode at a time like they
used to when you know we had 24 episodes
they had to um but with the streaming
series now they film them more like they
film movies and um and and how movies
are done they'll set up in one location
they film everything for that bit
regardless of the order which is why
sometimes you can just tell in movies
and it'll be a bit later on in the film
but it's in the same sort of thing and
you're like oh I'm pretty sure you film
this on the same day and I don't know
what feel about it whatever but anyway
um and then you get continuity errors or
you get
rewrites and rewrites are what kill the
shows and stuff I think to be honest
yeah but then when you get a rewrite
that affects something that you filmed
months ago sometimes they forget and as
little errors creep in they like I the
story's changed but anyway
um I I just think I I think ekko's
really good I think Loki's been really
good I'm really looking forward to the
finale of that I think it's in a twisty
turny little little bugger but it's
actually I'm actually a bit concerned
about that because it's not the not the
final episode of Loki I'm concerned
about it's the supposed post credit
scene tying in the
Marvels
I don't even I've I've seen a couple of
trailers for the Marvels and I know
someone that's seen it right or seen a
pre a pre-cut of it and they said it's
pretty good and they hated Doctor
Strange too I mean this person messaged
me about a week before um it came out
and when you are going to spit up a lung
when you watch this film and I was like
really and he's like yeah it's really
bad um especially because he knew I
really like the first doctor strange and
just like CGI and he was the one that
told me that CGI amazing yeah oh
brilliant it says the CGI is awful and I
was under this sort thing I'm like
really um and um and and I was like say
yeah I I I love bits of Doctor Strange 2
but I hate bits as well and but he's
told me yeah he says the Marvels he was
shocked he came out of the Marvels he
went in expecting to hate it and came
out and was like it's quite good so so
let's um I don't get me wrong I don't
think he's um well let's hope that let's
hope that bleeds into to the audience
that go and see it because I mean they
need something positive at Marvel right
now because everything you know a lot of
what they've done recently has just not
been great not being good at all you
know even I won't even mention the uh
the the the season that should have
remained a
secret no let's mention it because that
was Bloody the secret Invasion how do
you get
Sam Jackson playing one of the coolest
characters one of the coolest actors
alive to play one of the coolest
characters and it's dull boring and
makes no
sense the whole thing at the end the
whole battle sequence at the end no
sense I'm going to go around the battle
scene and we're going to collect blood
and we're going to have DNA and we're
going to make superheroes that's not how
blood works that's not how DNA works and
you can't just that's not how battle
scenes it's just
thick it was thick it was it's kind of
like the the the idea that people
believe that cars fall off a cliff and
blow up which was in the movies not real
life I love that scene in thingy hero
with um Arnold Schwarz [__] and he
comes out movie and he shoots it doesn't
explode he's
like shut up
kid I'm G to shoot the petrol tank and
nothing happens because it wouldn't
scene where he was he jumps somewhere
and he goes ow that hurt yeah
yeah never hurt before yeah exactly yeah
that was brilliant Bruno
Fernandez huge goal huge goal thank God
for that we need those three points
anyway carry with um with Last Action
Hero the bit where they walk into the
video shop in the in the uh in the movie
screen and it's like you got the
Terminator and it's
actually Stone
I reckon it pretty to have like like a
separate Terminator movie
was um I love the um the room well it's
not the rumors the um the story about
how they two used to wind each other up
and um and Arie actually convinced
Lester Stone to do um my mama I threw my
mama off a train thing um because he
basically said I'm really really gonna I
really really want it and Sylvester SLO
was like no no and and fought for it and
actually AR was like and he knew it was
awful
just been tricked him basically into
doing a terrible film um but
um have you watched um it's on Paramount
at the moment the Tulsa King with with
um Sylvester slow yeah I actually liked
that I adore it I am loving it I am uh
about seventh episode at the moment so
don't spoil it for me but
it's man you you got a lock
coming you think you you do it now
you're can absolutely love it at the end
ah he's just been to New York he's just
buried his brother and um but it's so
good and if anybody everyone says
everything Hollywood does his work every
Hollywood does his work no way it's not
work it's really good it's only the on
in Hollywood that they say he going to
be a blockbuster they're the ones oh
yeah yeah yeah I just don't I don't
agree well you know if anybody know I
don't agree with that but I do agree
that some stuff
is some stuff is a crap but I would just
argue that we've always had crap movies
always had crap just usually the crap is
B movies well
yeah we just forget about them we forget
about the the crap I think Huds and Hawk
is a terrible film but you know
people yeah it was the most expensive
movie ever made when it came out but um
anyway how well yeah I think it was
mostly Bruce Willis's paycheck I think
it was an interest interesting um idea
to follow that catburger you know it was
it was an adventure you for me you know
to watch it I don't I don't quite know
why it bombed so badly but it was just
it was um maybe a little bit too silly
but anyway we're wandering we're
wandering yeah we
are what we actually came on to talk
about was monster movies because I mean
there's a couple of really exciting
projects coming out the is going to get
a big
[Music]
boost me and you were chatting just
before we came on we basically said like
the um very similar to the um the Planet
of the Apes movies they've been very
quietly just making money doing good
films not not blowing up the box office
by any stretch of the imagination but um
creating a
franchise that makes sense that's like
but the other franchise a bit like that
is also the Godzilla franchises and the
King Kong crossover and they've been
quietly brilliant yep they
have and I would argue that King Kong in
particular and and and Kong versus
Godzilla that film should have been
stupid but actually it worked I'm glad
you said it that way because even though
they released it as Godzilla versus Kong
it's actually should be the other way
around because it's mostly about Kong
well yeah um it was yeah it was mostly
about Kong you're right um but are my
kids love my kids can't I cannot make my
kids watch a Marvel film now love the
money but they will quite happily sit
and watch King Kong films they love them
well that's the great thing about
Monarch it's going to it's it's going to
show the aftermath of everything from
San Francisco all the way up to Hong
Kong and stuff like that so it's going
to be
incredible I think that's going to talk
we again we talked about the new
Japanese movie that's just come out the
um well it came out a couple of months
ago I think came out in August in it in
Japan but we might get over it in the
Godzilla minus one oh my God it's based
just after World War II and it's um you
know the nuclear attacks on Japan
basically triggered this and and and
Godzilla came out and then you know you
got a country devastated by War and then
it gets
back if you haven't seen the trailer
again go and watch it immediately and
and keep a very close eye on the special
effects and also this is how you promote
a franchise oh yeah oh hell yeah the way
they promoted it would just teas us no
full cinematic trade or anything
that is the way to do
it minimal
minimal but when you watch the special
effects and I'm going to say realism is
the word I want you to think about when
you look at the special effects the way
Godzilla lobs a ship and it hits a
building the way it hits the way it then
moves is it twists and breaks Buck yeah
it's not
like like Hollywood special effects it's
it's done very realistically once or
twice you see Godzilla's big feet and
he's like crushing people and think oh
that looks like a guy in a suit um but
then the next shot is just like oh it's
beautifully done but um I do wonder if
they've thrown in a few little shots
that look like a guy in a suit as a
throwback to the original movies
potentially um well I think from what
I've seen and heard I've I've got an
opinion
that they they wanted to articulate it
in a more realistic way and what's more
realistic than you know just CG eying
what appears to be a guy in a suit
because the articulation just going to
be
perfect
yeah someone actually mentioned about
the size of Godzilla's feet in it it's
like well they're meant to be that big
he's a big
animal well yeah yeah yeah but it looks
really cool the Godzilla looks a bit
like the Godzilla from the Hollywood
movie so it ties in um I I think it's
gonna be beautiful but the thing I like
about monik um rise of monsters it's
going to be on Apple um which again just
this is just show that Apple
really love you know it's quality over
quantity all day with apple
um a lot on Apple even now and mean a
lot of stuff is it is spectacular stuff
that they got on there Foundation looks
incredible and stuff like that so it's
really good the nice thing I like about
Foundation is all of the dollars are on
the page as well you know they spent 45
million quid to make this first the
second series of Foundations ships look
ugly but you know you forgive it for
looking so
good well I mean 45 million quid is what
they were spending on an episode of
rings of P so I mean once You' taken all
the expenses but um four four to five
millionar an episode for sci-fi nowadays
is what they were spending on the
expanse five or six years ago it's
incredible value for money
um so so monik um rise of monsters Kurt
Russell and his son because it's two
time periods 1950s in modern day bring
back something that happened once before
because uh in soldier in
98 Wyatt played a young
K
ah before yeah like I like it when they
bring family in and it's like yeah
reallyy good yeah
oh Monarch is is going to show a lot of
interesting things about Godzilla as
well about his history which is going to
be good and the general Monsters the
general wider thing as well because I
mean there's there's that insect looking
thing that we're going to be getting in
a few other things so again it's
expanding the monster verse that we've
already seen some of we saw there
something that I find lacking in the
legendary ones is we don't see enough of
the other of the other monsters in the
monster in in that uh go Godzilla verse
call it Godzilla verse and you know you
got Rodan we got Rodan in king of the
monsters right we got a few of the other
ones but they don't look right whereas
um what I've seen in Monarch uh we're
gonna see a more of the traditional ones
that his traditional enemies and his
friends which looks really good so monik
Davis is the TV show that's going to be
on Apple Plus um go and check out the I
think we they've they've dropped two
major trailers and they've just dropped
two or three days ago a sort of like a a
mini documentary behind the scenes type
of trailer we haven't got long to wait
for the for the show to start either
it's it's two weeks isn't it it's a
couple of weeks something like that so
um but monik is the sort of
the it's it's a company isn't it that
was it's a privatized company that sort
of like was search and they were they
captured a couple the big butterfly
thing that was the company
they never been able to capture one but
they managed to contain them when
they're asleep yeah but when they wake
up that's when all hell breaks loose
yeah yeah the big butterfly sort of went
n [__] off and they really annoyed me
when they killed moo in king of the
monsters
yeah stupid Mothra Mothra is important
in the Godzilla verse not anymore he's
dead extremely important yeah um but
yeah maybe is going to go a different
way but um maybe maybe there is another
moth about to hatch you never know moth
is is a slightly silly and not very
terrifying monster even though hey a
moth flies into my house I don't know
why it scares me so much but they do but
um the thing is um The Moth we in King
the monsters is looks very very um evil
you got the big big um moth wings and
then all of sudden you got that little
thing with all the spiky plaws and stuff
no that don't look right was that no
it's a terrifying um but yeah I I I just
yeah I mean I'm really looking forward
to that I'm really looking forward to
see if we have another movie follow it
up um the thing I like about monik RIS
of monsters though is that I mean from
what we've seen it's movie cinematic
quality it look it really the monsters
are excellent the thing and and we're
really going to get an in-depth look at
the story because it's not just setting
one storyline it's you know it's we it
should be absolutely fascinating um and
just one more reason why the wife will
let me keep apple because we started
watching slow horses um a couple weeks
ago which is a fantastic spy series and
again you've got got to watch it it's
just it's it's just fantastic um really
really brilliant
old I haven't I haven't really taken a
look a lot on Apple recently been doing
other things but yeah I might take a
look at that give give give um slow
horses ago if you particularly if you
like like Spooks and things like that
back in the day um BBC ITV sort of
Thrillers but it's done with a bit of an
edge to it it's really good really good
um proper acting as well um David Bailey
is that the one that's on Netflix the
three parter I think
is I don't know the G I saw one when
I the future not sure about that don't I
don't remember that that has Godzilla
Earth which is Godzilla a th feet tall
yeah the biggest he's ever
been um so the show is going to be which
show Richard are you on about the monic
so we got the monic show rise of
monsters um but we've mentioned a few
shows in the last two minutes so I think
what you mean um yeah ryen monster is
going to be apple plus and Premier in
the next couple of weeks I've got the
11th in my head but I'm might might be
wrong um I did look but I didn't write
to there so um the other big monster
movie coming though and we got two
actually we got a movie and a series is
the return aliens franchise oh
yes we've got alien Romulus which is
going to be the movie based Star Trek
crossover yeah yeah and we haven't got
an official name for the series yet I
don't think it's just called alien at
the moment right now but I remember
correctly it's going to be based on a
cybernetic company I think creating
Androids that sort of
thing there's going to be um we do know
a little bit about it because Noah Hy um
basically came out and talked about this
a little bit in the last couple of weeks
and for one thing so filming already
started it started in July even though
all the actors are on strike because
it's being filmed in Thailand and it's
mostly British actors excuse me um so
they had an agreement with sag after
sort of thing um but they did get paused
in August because they sort of went okay
we're taking the piss now um when
everybody want to
strike um we know it's set 70 years
before the uh 1979 aliens movie Alien
movie so that would have been set in
2122 so this film should be sit set 2050
sort of time quite close to where we are
yeah so set in future on Earth is the
three big corporations and
Wayland Yami
yatti yeah it's um but it's supposed to
be a competing company with Wayland at
the time and Wayland by that comp to
three competing companies um doing
different sides of the same thing and
whan are going to have an alien egg Bas
at that point it would have been whand
because then utani would be one of the
other companies possibly maybe that's
where the series is going that they'll
get because I know I know that
eventually in um in the other movies in
the original movies wayy
utani um utani buys
wayand
Industries and that's why it's called
Wayland utani in Aliens is it I think in
Alien it was still whan in Aliens it
became whing utani if I remember
correctly I can't be 100% sure though
long that point at one point the Ser
everyone thought the series was going to
be called whand but that seems to have
been dropped at some point
um and Filman is supposed to restart
anytime apparently apparently as soon as
the contract done ready to go again
because they've not been shut down very
long I think Romulus is in post
production right now is it romen is in
post production it should be out um
August
2024 that's the current day um and
Ridley Scott has seen an early version
of it and it very happy he absolutely
Ador um the one thing about the series
before we talk about the movie properly
the one thing about the series is this
Noah Hy talked about how he sort of
mirrored um the Xenomorphs life the way
the xenomorph Works sort of thing sort
of mirrored in the show so it says the
the way he was describing it was the
face huggers
a slow and um you know a methodical sort
of creature yeah and then you get the
implant and it's secretive and there's
it's hidden and it's you know a um
growing inside you sort of thing the
threat growing from within and then you
get the monster you know which is the
monster which is a G oh sorry no wrong
franchise but still intelligent though
it's an intelligent creature but it's
just terrifying and and and animalistic
I think well I always say that the
aliens are like ants ants are really
intelligent and they got a heart mind so
that's what I see it and even even bees
and wasps are the same the high their
intelligence is quite high so that's
what I compare them with yeah it it
won't have anything to do with Ripley no
simply because it's set both there was
there was a rumor early on that it was
going to be based around her daughter
but that ended up being the computer
game didn't it yeah I believe so yeah so
so that that's going to be um that yeah
so we've already film has already
started on the series we we're getting
that soon alien Romulus um this the Star
Trek Crossover with the Romy luns
obviously um uh the um that is um
already in postproduction so it's
already been filmed um and post
production is carried on because they've
not been affected by the strikes ridle
got is producing and it's it's directed
by fed
Alvarez the one thing we know that all
we really know about it is that um alare
as I said it's going to be very dark
very frightening it's going back to a
horror movie it's not going to be um
thing um a very young cast which doesn't
really mean anything I don't mind that I
don't mind that at all because I'm okay
it depends it depends is it a young cast
on a on a spaceship like the original or
or along those lines because that would
make more sense because the crew would
be young than through hyperspace in
hyper sleep they might still age which
would make sense that's the thing I
don't actually know that much about
because they've been
really um and it's all been recorded on
like sound stages and things so they've
been very good at like keeping it um
under wraps um I know a guy again
actually to be fair the guy that I was
talking to about earlier who who gets to
see a few of these things um in in early
things he's dying to see it and he's not
he's not seen
it yeah um and he he keeps trying to
like sneak his way in to try and get
like a pre preview but they haven't made
many they've not they've not done
normally they would do lots of these
preview showings and try to get um
opinion on the project and stuff and
they've not done many with this because
I think they only agreed on the Romulus
title remaining a couple of months ago
because originally it was only a
temporary title but now they're going to
keep it r s yeah I believe so um at the
moment anyway I mean it's still eight 10
months aliens no no two
know yeah um Teen Angst and then goes oh
my God my hair and then an alien just
eatting
um when did you get dreadlock dreadlocks
I was gonna make a pronouns joke then
but I better not
um I I I just I just think it's a yeah I
I I think it's a really good time for
aliens I just think we got the series
and the movie coming out um I just
realized about the the series I didn't
think of it before I don't know why but
with the series they could they could
actually show other aliens I wouldn't
mind a an appearance maybe a predator or
two well that was going to be my next
Point Predators just had prey yeah which
again was a strip back PR two haven't
they they've announced pray two and we
don't know a lot about that yet
um the original theories were it was
going to be mud blood again but I've
heard a rumor that it's
not um and that actually it's going to
be a similar sort of idea as prey it's
just going to be set in a different time
frame again yeah um and we'll get to see
again a different slightly different
variation on the the story line um which
I think is good I think is probably
going to be a idea because I think doing
another
one similar to prayer would have been
difficult because we had the ending
sequence didn't we on pray with the all
the other alien ships coming in so
everyone initially was like well there's
actually um theories about that going
around wasn't there there was a theory
saying that the aliens had come down to
show their respect to the to the small
human and maybe take her away and she
she's supposed she may been originally
supposed to become this a legendary
human Predator that they take away and
train and stuff but that's what was done
in the comics a few times yeah um so
yeah that was the rumor at the time um I
think I even shared that rumor at the
time um but I I know for a fact this was
pretty much green lit 18 months ago as
soon as pretty much green lit after
after PR came out to be honest in my
opinion it was it was it was green lit
it was I mean that was producers already
talking about how do we get this done um
you know um and then it's really just
being the director and the producer
trying to figure out the best way to do
it um and that's just took a little
while then obviously had the strikes and
blah blah blah
um crsh tribles crossover well yeah
um crit was a funny little franchise
that
was about eight films in the end and
they just got more and more random they
were completely you couldn't more more
silly that's what you loved about them
yeah there was no then made no logical
sense I'm like what the [__] is going on
but anyway
um yeah but then my next thing was
thinking an AVP
crossover again but done
well David thank you so much for the
Super Chat yeah uh what movie you
excited about going to the cinema
for
I don't think there's anything coming
out yet oh actually there's a new Nick
Cage film um a comedy that I do fancy
watching I might go watch next week um
dreams in dreams or dream man or
something um but let's have a look
because David B very very polite very
kindly Cinema releases 2023 let's see
what's coming out and we'll pick
something between us shall we Melvin see
what's coming
out um it's probably we've mentioned
already in this video we've mentioned a
couple hav we already yeah
um science fiction films coming
out Transformers I didn't watch it don't
want to watch
it
um black demon what the hell is
that oh that's um that's about a shark a
spirit
shark yeah what what have you seen this
year so far that you
enjoyed
you that's loads um I really
enjoy for me there's a difference
between enjoyed and actually like it's
like I I'm enjoy I enjoyed Ahsoka but
that doesn't mean I like Ahsoka if that
makes sense but um as for um excited
about a movie coming out in theaters
I'll probably say Godzilla minus
one all right even though it's not going
to be widely um released um I think it
was something like 200 Cinemas across
both us and UK so it's not a huge
release that's the that's the only
problem with it in my opinion yeah um
yeah we're not going to get a full on
thing I tell you what film I was really
like ridiculously disappointed by was
John Wick for it was just B and we have
a new member as well thank you very much
so um most of our videos if you're a m
you will get to see most of the videos
about an hour before everybody else
because YouTube have got a new way of
doing it so I can actually set it up
really easily so I'm like yay so members
now get to see the videos about an hour
before everyone else thank you YouTube
for doing that it's a very nice way of
doing it really appreciate it um I'm
trying to see any films that are still
waiting to come out that I want to see
and I am
struggling I can't see got a couple of
months left don't we so
yeah
um I am really looking forward to alien
when it comes out but that's going to be
next year
um I don't know I don't think there are
any anything really really exciting um
cinema movies coming up let's have a
look coming soon Wonka nope not
interested in
that um Captain America Brave New World
oh of course that's the um first no I
won't be watching that no no Aquaman 2
no won't be watching
that
um the second June I'm looking forward
to that that won't be till next year now
Beetle Juice
too it's been too
long it's dangerous isn't
it right okay no John Wick was not John
Wick four was not awesome it wasn't
right for one since when did John Wick
become Wolverine or something because he
he he was thrown off third story
building landed on a van and then just
sort of got up and went
oh what and I know the French are
ignorant right but they're having a
massive fight sequence around the Arc of
Triumph and all these cars are going
round and round and round and they're
all shooting like bouncing off cars and
whatever and not a single car stopped
and went hey what are you doing it's
like don't know why he became a Boston
person then but um I know are ignorant
but for God's sake and the staircase
scene in John Wick 4 went on so long I
started collecting my pension halfway
through um which was you know I I was I
was 24 years old when I walked into that
movie and just the staircase sequence of
you had more hair as well you want me
hair was longer as well yeah I had hair
when we went in so did I exactly so I
mean it was just bad um and it was it
was just too long if it again if it
about an hour lobbed out of it it was
been great the first John Wick film is
still one of the best um action movies
we've had for a decade easily it
stunning I feel that John Wick's first
the first John Wick film was actually
filmed along the lines of the old old
way of doing action films yeah 1980s
action movie yeah old school
exactly um there is another Godzilla
Kong movie being planned actually which
I've forgotten about G to the new Empire
XCOM
next yeah that'll be end of next year by
the
looks against two monsters um the red
Kong which is the scar I can't remember
his name but he's got it's more like a
chimpanzee version of Kong yeah longer
arms red fur and um and there's another
monster that's um supposed to be able to
help
well the red Kong is supposed to be able
to have um mind control over over other
Kongs so that's going to be interesting
to see if they put that in it okay I'll
just say traditionally it's in the comic
books or something like that yeah I mean
that's the thing isn't it
um so much in the
comics that you know there's a lot to
lot to go through yeah June 4 2024 I
think it's been is been pushed back
again
though no I don't think they've pushed
it back any further supposed to be this
Christmas wasn't it and they pushed it
back I don't know I was supposed to be
this month when it was supposed to be
November originally I think yeah it's
been pushed back a couple of
times Aquaman
2 I'm no interest in it at all um i'
love Jason Mamoa yeah I adore the man
but um he was the only good thing in the
first yeah call back to Stargate man go
do a ronin Dex movie it' be much much or
even even if you haven't got the time to
just voice a Ronan Runner series yeah
animated exactly if you go to prodes MGM
and say you do it they'll do
it they'll do it but let's see but
anyway bud um that's that's an hour mark
we've talked about what did we talk
about everything we wanted to talk about
pretty much and more I think yeah we
wandered a little bit i' got a sore
throat yeah I think I might have been
getting a thing shall popcorn Powers
with us shall I arrange the marriage
what you you talking
about um I don't know there might be
something in the um comments that made
make sense there might be something I
haven't really been able to follow it
that much and and secular we are allowed
to disagree sir and that is the joy of
of I I I try very hard to to say that no
opinion unless it's really stupid is
wrong on this on this channel U oh Jason
Mamoa yes please do I I love the man
he's he's just think my wife wife
actually my wife might fight me for him
to be fair because my wife really likes
him it's it's unfortunate to be honest
um does anybody remember impostor with
Gary CES and meline Stow I don't I
vaguely remember imposter I'm not I
couldn't tell you what happens in it but
I vaguely remember
it is it a TV
show or a
movie Gary sinness Gary sinness has done
so many shows that then got cancelled
like almost immed this is going to be a
musical it's going to be a musical says
Joker 2 is also coming out soon it is
going to be a musical yeah it's oh I
don't watch it I didn't want to watch
first one I don't remember this
fil
garyi I'm looking at the posters now
don't remember it Napolean should be
called secular and I think it's actually
available isn't it it's available to
stream now is it I remember correct
it's not out yet is it I don't think I
think
I I'm not sure ISB brother wolfy yeah I
don't remember it I don't remember
imposter so I'll have to I'll check it
out I do like remember it but I remember
The
Pretender yeah um I think um but yeah
um I was going to say something then
there's a film that's just come out and
I'm saying it's just a remake of
something else it's gone I is there a
film that's out recently that wasn't a
remake or something else I think almost
every film is though isn't it that's the
thing tell me how many times can you
write an original movie it's all going
to end up being based on something
that's done before it isn't it there's
basically like six stories they're
Reckoning their basic stories and and
and everything I mean because I was
talking about um and Marvel have all of
them well yeah but I was talking about
basically um like Firefly reboot with
somebody in the week and they were sort
of saying and and there seems to be the
plan is in the first film we'll see Mal
sort of broken and um and you know he's
given up after everything that happened
to Serenity losing wash and then the you
know the gang got broke up I could
imagine him living in serenities on
someck dirt piling off Planet somewhere
yeah it's broken and yeah you know yeah
living in the wreck of the ships Firefly
when he in the is it was it the out of
gas episode where where we first see him
as he sees F Serenity for the first time
it's like PA money for this sir on
purpose but that's the sort of thing I'd
like to see in in in shows and that you
see the character actually fall in love
with something an instant that they see
it yeah and I would love to see that in
the first film them him you know and and
maybe that's how the first film ends
with him actually getting the Firefly
back into the black you know that's how
the first film ends sort thing but um
that'd be cool and they River holds many
secrets well yeah but their argument was
you know why do films always have to
start with the the character broken I
said well they don't have to but it's
more interesting we want to see you know
but actually with the Firefly thing
because of what happened in Serenity it
makes sense that he would be
broken what I don't
like what was that bring the band back
together and you know go off but
um I don't like it when something like
um Star Wars with um
Obi-Wan oh he started off miserable and
then he comes back and he's quite like
um positive again towards the end but he
goes off on his own again and I'm like
yeah but no something else must happen
because he's miserable again next time
we see him yeah so how does he go back
so he story arc is that
he was sort of
broken sort of was was was on a recovery
or was was becoming positive again sort
of thing and then becomes sort of like
broken and miserable Again by the time
New Hope starts and I'm like why does he
well it's it's his connection to the
force I think because we see him
struggling with the force in Obi-Wan
right yeah so he's lost his connection
he's only got very minimalistic ability
to use it but then as he's fighting to
save Leia you he's just
suddenly starting to get his power back
he's and at the point where um at the
point where he confronts Vader in the
final fight um he's actually come to
terms with a lot of stuff he blamed
himself for what happened to Anakin
that's major part of that story right
and the fact that he's come there and
then Vader's actually said you didn't
destroy Anakin and I did and then all of
a sudden there he is he's got all his
full for full force on steroids
basically and then he spanked Vader with
a big rock but yeah and then and I
suppose by the time we see him again
actually in New Hope he is he doesn't
really blame himself of Vader and he has
come to terms with a lot of it he's just
he's
defeated but he's not tortured like he
was the Maj
thing problem I had with uh with Obi-Wan
is they could have just canceled A New
Hope
there canel it out basically right then
and saved a lot of trouble and millions
upon millions of lives being dragged out
of their windows and doors how many how
many films have we seen that that over
the years they were just like oh I'm not
sure that makes sense because if this
had happened then all that I love the um
you said that in the argument for
Indiana Jones and the um Raiders that
lost Arc and somebody points out that um
nothing that happens in that film has
any re relevance to anything that
Indiana Jones does if actually if he
hadn't have been in the film the Nazis
wouldn't have found the Arc in the first
place but it's a relevant if they would
have done because they'd have opened it
and all died anyway so actually Indiana
Jones has absolutely know it's a
complete waste of time and if he hadn't
have been there it would have all been
better probably because they would found
it in the first place and I'm
like
yeah
she down the map then balen wouldn't
have found
it
yeah I don't know um anyway thank you so
much for joining us Melvin it's been a
joy as always um again soon we will
there is a link in the channel you're
doing a lot of babyon 5 videos at the
moment like you said doing very well so
please guys go and subscribe to Melvin
and his sci-fi Quest and that would be
very nice then come and join us tomorrow
Harris has got an announcement about his
channel
tomorrow and we're going to be doing our
presidential debate where we are going
to decide for Amazon what they need to
do with the series or movie and I've got
to think in my argument because I've got
Series so actually I could just sit
there and just basically go 90% 97% of
fans want a series is there anyone going
to be there that's to say I'm neutral
I'm in the middle I want
both well no you can't have both one one
has got to come before the other one
always leads to the other so a few
people have actually said well I'm
greedy I just want both and go well you
might get both but that's not the point
of the argument the point of the thing
is they were going to do a movie first
and know they might do a serious first
so what should they do first it's
irrelevant if we then get the movie or
the series afterwards what are they
gonna be first isant what we get yeah
the rumor is um that we're going to
get well they've got a fiveyear plan is
the is the rumor that I'm hearing at the
moment and this is what MGM want to do
but Amazon haven't signed off is they
want to do three
seasons then of one of a
show there will be then a one season
prequel show mixed in there um and then
at some point in that first three years
there'll be a Amazon Prime
movie then another season of something
else and then a big movie at the end of
that fiveyear period that's the plan I
think I think I'm getting that right
three
seon three seasons of one show over the
five years a prequel show an Amazon
Prime movie and then another Amazon Prim
movie at the end of the five years it's
basically a fiveyear first chapter idea
so basically where will we be in five
years yeah exactly so um I think that's
right one question that everyone's like
oh I don't
know basically we'll get four seasons of
television and two movies in a 5year
period That's What MGM want to do um but
those movies would be straight to Prime
movies they wouldn't be like and they
would end
the sort thing I'm bit curious about
that because that does that mean you're
going to get a movie in between the
seasons I think so I think the point is
you get three seasons so you'll get two
seasons of the Prime TV show then a
prequel series then a
movie then it'll get the third season of
whatever the prime show is and then
another movie kind of like what the what
Disney are doing with Star Wars where
you got all these shows that that don't
look like they tie in but they all going
to tie in yeah that's the whole point
it' be one major story arc or all all
building towards that second movie is
the is is the idea MGM have but I mean
as far as I understand they have
absolutely no storyline idea I'm not
sure that following Disney in that
direction is the right way to go to be
honest they've been talking about doing
a Star Wars style or Marvel style phases
that that's the conversation that I've
heard from going two years back that
that's what Amazon wanted to do um so
we'll see
um but yeah new has approached many
countries yeah um I and I think that's
Jenny sten's basic idea that we'd have
starget international I think I think
Amazon would be very keen to do that and
me and Jenny have basically separately
heard the same rumor that that that that
might be the way they're going to go
because Amazon want to
um produce TV shows around the world for
different
audiences that then people will watch
because Netflix has proven that people
watch South Korean television in their
Millions um so they would watch it it'd
be primarily
for brilliant did you watch did you did
you see space sweepers when that came
out yeah yeah that was really good movie
yeah I enjoyed it um but but anyway
we'll we'll see because like I say
at the moment as far as I understand it
the movie is still the
plan either way I'm watching it well
yeah it's just that they seem to be open
to the possibility of changing their
minds which is fine i' be happy with say
one season and then the climax of that
season being a movie which then leads
into season two that might be a good
idea yeah yeah yeah I think so whatever
I think it'll be all intertwined anyway
um I've I've had a few comments this
week morons going oh you just click
bating you've been saying this is going
to happen for ages and now you seen some
else well I'm just like all I can do is
tell you what's happening it's up to you
what you do with the information I don't
control the information I can just say
this is what this is what's happening
there plenty ofers out there and it's
obvious that you're not doing it I'm
just saying well I I try not to I think
the thing with click baiting right is
that I think you you've got to a little
bit which is a bit but at the end of the
day you want to do a title that people
will go h i fancy watching that I wonder
what it is so I try to like put in
questions in my title if I can um you
can't with everything sometimes it's
just you know like news whatever but I
I'll try to do like oh could this happen
or I Tred to do it in a way you know you
try to do a a click thing that that
people will go ah so if you want to call
that clickbait in because it is really
I'm trying to I'm trying to get you to
click I'm trying to I'm trying to
interest you I'm trying to hook you you
know but or there's click baiting which
is
just a lie in the tile yeah and it's not
then the video won't be anything to do
with what you clicked on
yeah issues with I mean uh I I watch
talking about United who who I love most
who won come on three points and there
is a channel that I watch called the
United stand which is U and they
clickbait all the time and it's quite I
mean it's a brilliant Channel and they
always talk about the news and stuff but
they will
say um man united sale final and that's
the title and then the video is
basically about okay there this person
has talked about the the video that the
sale is final but isn't and blah blah
blah and I'm like oh come on you're not
even talking about what the title is
that's clickbait secular monk no we
don't what's secular monk we need a
musical episode of Stargate dear Lord no
we
don't now we had the 200th episode
that'll do that'll do pig that'll
do and before that we'll have a
crossover episode where the infinity
group come through the
Stargate yeah okay I want to see the
crossover where doctor who comes through
the gate myself I'm still waiting for
Obie in Loki to go Dr Jones
yeah
don't yeah I love OB in that I think
canot believe that actor couldn't get a
job for like 20 years and now he's one
of the hottest properties in Hollywood
he was in Indiana Jones for out yeah he
was the best thing in it and and and he
was the best thing in
um yeah Short Round And then he was the
best thing in playing data as well in um
in The Goonies he was best thing in that
as well and then couldn't get a job for
25 years anyway why how is that
possible I don't know I don't know right
anyway
thank you so much sir um we're GNA call
it a day I don't know why but I've got a
sore throw so I'm hoping I'm gonna be
right we have 15 minutes over
there yeah exactly but you know we
started talking about Stargate again so
my notes gone um we'll have you again an
hour ago it yeah yeah so we'll have you
back very shortly sir have a lovely
weekend and guys you too thank you very
much we will see you tomorrow um I'll be
in the chat tomorrow get in the chat
yeah and um guys come and join us um the
video is already up so you can set your
reminders now thank you so much we'll
see you later uh I always do this and I
always I'm never ready to actually click
the
button okay byebye Melvin bye
[Music]
byebye oh shut up I'm
kidding